well meanwhile yes here in america
yes we do have problems though they are
different in scale disruptions at gas
stations across the southeast as a
critical pipeline remains shut down
due to a cyber attack huge lines formed
across multiple states yesterday
as panicked americans started a run on
gas according to gas
buddy nearly 1800 gas stations are out
of fuel
florida virginia north carolina and
georgia have declared states of
emergency
while american airlines says it is
adding stops to some long-haul flights
so planes can refuel
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in atlanta david good morning
to you
the average price for a gallon of gas is
right now at the highest it has been in
nearly seven years
how are people reacting people are
panicking tony and it's hurting
all of us take a look at this picture
out of alabama this lady filling up gas
cans in the back of her vehicle is
exactly
what we're all being asked not to do
where we are in atlanta this morning
30 of stations are reportedly out of
fuel this is like when we ran out of
toilet paper and lysol during the
pandemic because everybody made a run on
the grocery store
we have enough gas in this country it's
just a matter of hauling it to where it
needs to be
so please experts are asking don't panic
we got a call from family that said you
better fuel up before you hit tennessee
there is panic at the pump from virginia
all the way down to florida
i would suspect just prices would go way
up i didn't suspect that there wouldn't
be any
the next day hundreds of gas stations
across the region
are starting to run out we put a stop to
the can sales today people were coming
in and loaded
trying to buy you know five and ten cans
worth of gasoline they're just hoarding
it
the pipeline sends oil from houston
texas to linden new jersey near new york
city
hackers breached the company's computer
system so colonial was forced
to shut down the pipeline cutting off a
major source of gasoline jet fuel and
diesel
to several states here's what panic
buying could do
hurt consumers long term warns gas buddy
petroleum analyst
patrick dehaan the first thinking is oh
boy prices are going to skyrocket and i
need to fill everything i come with gas
and so
that's a self-fulfilling prophecy that
actually makes the problem much more
acute
this chaos left in the wake of colonial
pipelines ransomware attack
has heightened concerns about america's
cyber security
the energy grid and water supply have
almost no
federally mandated cyber security
protections
and that vulnerability is costing
millions of dollars
listen to what homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas said on
tuesday
more than 350 million dollars in losses
are attributable
to ransomware attacks this year that's a
more than 300 percent
increase over last year's uh
victimization of companies
you know colonial pipeline isn't the
only ransomware attack happening right
now did you know it's also happening at
the washington dc police department
hackers have reportedly stolen all kinds
of information including personnel files
of police officers
and they're constantly releasing them
until their demands are met bottom line
anthony
some of the top officials in this
country say we could have
other infrastructure very